I'm really excited today to welcome
Martin Atkins to talks at Google.
He's an entrepreneur,
[inaudible]
Martins and entrepreneur and
educator, a musician, producer,
Dj,
and the list goes on with a 35
year career that spans genres,
borders and industries.
You could say that Martins,
the definition of entrepreneurial
activity in cultural arts endeavors.
So to call out a few things from
his massive list of accomplishments.
He was a member of public image limited,
founded the industrial
supergroup pig face,
contributed to nine inch nails for which
you won a grammy as well as ministry.
He's the owner of invisible records,
mattress factory recording studios and
he's the author of Book Smart Band,
smart tour smart. And I think I probably
left a few other titles out as well.
Uh,
he is also the father of four.
Martin is also the music business
chair at the ASAE institute Chicago.
I think a few of you guys are here
today and he's here to talk about the
creative industry with advice for artists,
musicians and entrepreneurs alike.
He has all kinds of tried,
tested and remixed ideas that all add up
to make a difference in a creative and
arts focused career. He'll share his
perspective around longevity, efficiency,
and having a mindset to plant
the seeds of your own future.
So for Googlers in the audience,
be sure to think of your
questions during the Q and a,
which we'll have up at the end.
So please join me in welcoming to
the Google stage, Martin Atkins
[inaudible]
thanks for that introduction.
That was kind of awesome.
You did miss out one of my books. Welcome
to the music business. You're fucked.
I think you miss that one.
Uh,
so yeah,
so I play drum set and I was nine
joined my first band when I was 11.
Started Drinking Newcastle Brown Ale
and backing strippers at the age of 12.
And it's just been, speaking of
longevity, it's just been a long, slow,
sad decline from Wa in retrospect
as a career high at the age of uh,
he said,
just a little bit of me,
my time with public image limited
Katrine Johnny rotten of the sex pistols
to the suicide goes
from American bandstand.
Hello.
What's your name please welcome to empty
the
nine inch nails to pig face.
Yeah.
Uh,
I just like seeing that me spitting and
hitting this ruining microphones and
stuff to my books and my third book,
I always forget to do this at the end,
so I want to do it now.
If you follow me on Twitter and a r. T. E.
E my hilarious eighties joke is for ease.
Just like the old days.
Yeah.
Laughter over here from both
students to sit in here going,
Oh, if you follow me on Twitter, you get
a free download of, of my second book. So,
well, I'm going to, but this
seems a little bit grandiose.
Little stuff, big stuff and huge
stuff, which is all I could think of.
How to describe, uh, this stuff first,
before we get into that,
I wanted to thank,
because here in Chicago I wanted
to thank chance the rapper, um,
for donating $1 million
to Chicago public schools.
But is anybody else thinking
about what you couldn't do 1.5,
you know,
how to say,
but without going off on too many
tangents before we get started,
do you have any idea how many types
of Kit Kat there are in Japan?
It's absolutely bonkers.
Soy Sauce, Ginger Ale.
I don't know what the
meeting was on that one.
Red Bean pumpkin baked potato kit Kat.
Yeah, and I'd love to say we're going
to try them on mark down on your cards,
which I don't have baked potato kit Kat.
I do have some kit kats.
Anybody wants to fucking throw out
some kickass now if some pay attention,
we're not having to Google the Lord.
I was stabbed in the eye with
a kit Kat piece will come out.
I see you. It's all
right. We'll go. We go.
Well or not.
So all we have time for,
does anybody want some kick counts?
It doesn't have kit kats
40. What should I just,
if I pass this over there,
will it get past you? Would you, you
could take a couple of pass it around.
That will work on a
system. Uh, also while I'm,
while I'm not on the subject.
Yeah,
I'm loving this book hitmakers
by Derek Thompson. I'm really,
really loving it.
I think he's the senior editor of
Vanity Fair market. Uh, the
Atlantic. It's just awesome.
And while I'm up here,
uh,
I just got Kevin Coval a 10th book,
which is slightly awesome too.
Okay, enough of that. Are
there any rockstars here today?
Let's try that again, Shelly. Hey,
Google is,
are there any rock stars here today?
Absolutely. That's more like a hand
in the air. Hand on your crotch.
Doesn't have to be your crutch.
Anybody's,
well that's good news because Jimmy
John's sandwich sharp is looking for some
stars. I don't mean to completely
deflate your ambitions,
but everything just keeps
changing all the time.
Except this slide,
which is in every presentation
I've given in the last, I dunno,
10 years,
stuff just keeps changing.
Paris got, well there's me
cat before periscope and no
sooner and I go like that.
I was at south by southwest two
years ago to kind of go, oh me a cat.
This is interesting.
Oh by the time my fingers hit the keys,
it didn't exist anymore.
And Paris got comes along and and that
Instagress was awesome and now they
changed the,
yeah,
I'm liking report a report.
Make sure still images look like video.
It's Kinda cool.
And this is just a catastrophe now.
A turntable FM.
Does vine still exist even?
Wow.
See it's a good job. I approached
it. That workers, yeah.
Mindspace it's back. No, it isn't.
It was even when it was back,
he was like, no, it is a
hoot.
Suite actually is awesome.
Landa is software that masters
your music in a heartbeat.
But as I said,
it's just a mess.
Instagress yeah, it was loving
it. Everything keeps changing.
A Dunkin donuts
making chicken sandwiches,
Burger King donuts,
little walls is gone, man. It's
called mad. I'm like, well,
is how this is not right?
I drove past Kentucky Fried Chicken
down by the white sox and it's,
and the sign outside says
stop on in for a cake.
No,
I'm not gonna Vinyl is back
from near extinction just to,
just after I threw all my vital away,
I through all the vinyl cassettes are
back and this was a cassette store day
2013 and punk is a beer,
right? Like I was in a band with
Johnny Ron for five years. Right.
I came up through punk in
London and now it's a beer.
I want to go to the factory
and see the production line.
Kids were doing yellow Mohawk
at least we still have anarchy.
Don't we hear of Google? We
still have anarchy. Don't link.
Sometimes I'll say to my kids,
hey kids,
you feel like a spot of only key today
and I, yeah, I've got four boys. Yes.
Dad was,
yeah,
the revitalizing shower gel from ax.
I don't remember what I, lucky smart
light. It's not that I tell you what.
There is also an a key for him.
That'd be smelted.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
Really bad that you just got
off a plane down. I said,
well, your your English, but
ladies.
Yeah,
and the key for her,
that just all just blew back.
Now here's a tip with anarchy for her.
You don't just spray it,
you spray it and then
you want to try some Chelsea,
Eddie, it's want to pick one.
It's terrible. It's
really, it's really bad.
It's just going to be
circulating now. Now, uh, yeah,
there's the anarchy a workout and
there's nothing you can do with
that credit card that makes it punk.
You could like buy a bag of
drugs with that critical. It's,
there's nothing you can do with
that card that will make it punk.
Okay.
Little stuff.
Let's look at some local stuff.
We'll move on to bigger stuff and
we'll get to the huge stuff. Well,
maybe we'll spend so much
time on the little stuff.
Who knows what's going to happen.
Fear of selling.
Get over it. You know, I,
I pulled up at a venue,
we were in Florida and I said to my
friend Chris Mackey, I was doing a talk.
I'm like, should I shouldn't
bring my merchant tonight?
You think it will sell? And
he said, really smartly, uh,
well you won't sell any if
you leave it in the car.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm protecting myself from
putting my wares on display,
which sounds selling my stuff.
I'm flying to sell my
shit and we all do that.
You've got to get your stuff
out the car and set it up.
And it's not about the selling of it,
although it is.
If you need gas money to get to the
next Gig, it's about the transaction,
which is never about money. It's a
transaction about uh, relationship.
Ah, rolling your tee shirts. This is
band related stuff. You Roll your shirts,
Kip job, I keep forgetting this
tiny little thing to have a tip jar.
I got an email from a band.
They said that tip the tip jar tip
as it shall become no saved our band.
I'm like, well, what do you
mean? Like, well it didn't,
but it kind of nearly
did after our first show.
We had a bit of an argument
and it was $15 in the tip jar.
And we took that and we went to
Denny's and we got like a band meal.
It felt like they'd been bought dinner
by some fictitious record label of what
good luck getting $15 out of a
record label, but an over dinner.
They talked about what was right about
the day and what was wrong about the day.
And it didn't say the band,
but he got them to the next show
and the $15 from the next tip jar.
Got them to the show after that. Just
tiny stuff that made a big difference.
You have to have it say
something smart on your tip jar.
Sexy people tip every time
you tip God saves a kitten.
Of course that needs to be changed.
Every time you tip,
we'll guillotine a kitten out the back.
That's a genre.
That's how you really make the,
uh,
and of course you need to have ambition.
Have more than one tee shirt.
Have a choice of shirts.
Your question cannot be [inaudible].
Would you like to buy a shirt?
Your question has to be blocking the exit.
Which one of these shirts are you
going to buy now? This one or that one?
It's a very different question.
Giveaway your songs all the time.
Give away everything all the time.
And some musicians still her like,
yeah,
we'll give away that demo or that crappy
live recording we did or the that makes
it didn't work out very well. That was
cheap. What's give that away. You can't.
You have to give away your
best stuff all the time.
You have got this one chance to start
a relationship. If you were a bakery,
you've got some smoked salmon things,
uh,
one watching the great
British baking show.
So I'm about to go off at some
flaky Vala vom pastry nightmare.
I'm honest. Yeah, great. Yeah, you've got
to watch it. Great British baking show.
Very real. Oh well, great. British
baking show and heroin. Really relaxing.
So you're this bakery and you've got
the smoked Salmon Boulevard thing that
costs you a fortune is
complicated and difficult to make.
You don't want to give that way.
We've also got some style bagel chips
that didn't turn out very well and some
somebody tripped,
drop them on the floor and now you've
got style Bagel chips that people didn't
really like. And there's probably
some cat hair mixed in with them too.
You can't give them away.
That's the end of your relationship with
your freestyle cat hair infested bagel
chips.
You've got to give away the smoked Salmon
Vala thing and there's a relationship.
Oh, I'm hungry. Anybody else hungry? Now
it's time to remove the protective cap.
So come on everybody.
This is leftover from my sports.
Let you remove.
So eighties business nineties
business was this, wasn't it?
Everybody's protecting their shit.
Oh,
that can't be how we act anymore.
You've got to put your
arms down to the side
and give people a hammer.
Here's the thing, the bigger
the hammer you give to somebody,
the less likely they are to
smash you in the Crotch with it,
right? If you do that,
if you put on the side,
you want to have my mind and you'd give
me some GI Joe Toy, miniature hammer. Oh,
find a what?
I'll kill you with it.
If you give me a sledge
hammer, I'd be like, Oh yeah,
here we go. Bring it on. Who?
That one too. I can't
mate. Let's go have a beer.
The bigger the hammer you give,
the less likely people are to
smash you in the crotch with it.
I don't just talk about this stuff.
This is my version of the hammer.
I did a thing on my website Christmas Eve.
Hey,
things are going pretty good for me.
If they're not going very well for you,
pick a discount
and Bolton by my sledgehammer slide
and I put those discounts.
It was,
I felt like punk rock to me,
right?
40% 50% 90% do you know the discount that
I didn't imagine people would use that
they used a lot?
I'm like,
holy crap.
Why would somebody use 0% when you've
got a choice of 30 50 90 I don't know,
but lots of people did because I gave
a big sledgehammer 90% next time I do
this, so I got busy, but I'm going to
do it again. I think I'll do 100% now.
I'm not just going to do
100% and they go on holiday,
I'm going to do 100% sit
by the laptop going, oh,
get ready to shut that down.
All temporary temporary, oh,
this servers crashed. Right.
Be Smart about it, but
it's trust that was selling.
Ah, that's not right is it?
It's trust that we're building.
It's trust that we're making.
It's trust that we choose to create
this obstacle course for in a way.
Yeah.
It's no real reason for this slide.
There's a quote from Chuck D's. I could
seem like, yeah, so what junk d says,
what you know is what you're saying
and what are you save is what you make,
but really it's just me and chuck the,
I was hanging out with Chuck d.
We go,
there's no more of that,
and it's like, check.
It's just me and you and
a Richard Branson anyway,
so protect your assets.
You need assets.
Always have something else to sell,
right? All this free stuff is great,
but if you only have one shot at
one song, one thing, you're screwed.
When you give it away, you need 10
more things and other things besides,
so when you give something away,
you're stimulating and creating this
other part of this relationship.
Bigger stuff.
You want to spread your message far and
wide. We start to think geographically.
We start to look at a map. Where are
we going to go now? Installed Jacuzzi,
go to culinary school, start
brewing amazing beer. Thanks.
Lance has one of my favorite beers in the
world. That is, I buy some extra beds.
These are the reasons things will
be better. Two years from now,
I met this woman in Cleveland and I don't
know if she was at a talk somewhere,
one of my talks and she said,
well at least I know wherever my son goes,
he'll have people helping him, protecting
him, but cool. How'd you know that?
And she shows me this book,
this tattered book,
you know one of those line books with
the pen stuffed in it and she did all of
those things.
She went to culinary school,
they put a laundry in
the basement for beds,
screaming internet and invited every band
coming through town to stay with them
and she made them breakfast. She
helped them with the laundry, right?
She did all of that cool stuff and
created connections for her son,
a safety net for her song. Like
that's genius. So we think,
how can we be huge in Cleveland?
Stay where you are and invite pants
from Cleveland to come stay with you and
then go and stay with them.
Of course someone will break up,
some of them won't answer
the phone when you call.
That's just the roll of the dice
that's on them. Don't just do more,
be more. Right. Um,
I got a nice piece on NPR about this.
I don't have time to talk you through it.
My blackberry jam scam a story.
If you go to NPR,
all songs considered that's,
there's a few nice stories actually.
Me planting trees for Bon Jovi's drama.
High Point for me.
What did he do with your summer?
I was planting trees for Bon Jovi.
Strummer
you've got to stay on top
of the newest technology.
It's like ironic why I'm
standing here with Google.
You've got to stay on top of all of them.
Newest Shit
really did. Was there, does
that mean, oh, it's me. Sorry.
That is me.
Yeah,
well I'm doing it. Google talk. Yeah,
no, say hilarious. Yeah,
it's a phone. Yeah,
but you do. I'm joking about
it, but you know it's important.
Technology, technology,
technology. You've got mail walk,
you've got mail,
but you're laughing.
He'd say it's 9.0 go all on my laptop.
One of my favorite things to do while
I'm in the green room at some conference.
I like Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee.
I'll make sure my volume is on full.
Make sure there's a bunch
of people sitting in the
grim talking about their new
startup and you're, oh, we're bootstrap
this and bloody blah, and I hit back.
I'm just like,
honestly,
I'm going to have to start traveling
with an ambulance or something cause the
whiplash.
When people hear that it's just fantastic
and I don't kind of get up and go,
ha ha, I have to sit there
and pretend like I'm an idiot,
but they're the idiots.
Oh,
we got a little bit off track there,
but let's,
let's get back to do something different.
It different,
do something different, do more of
what works and less of what doesn't.
That's the great thing about all
the apps and technology. These,
you can track something immediately.
This is a great idea. No,
it isn't change. It's a
right. Do something else.
Efficiency.
I got pulled into this all the time.
People want to do things more efficiently.
There's no such thing as efficiency.
We just sit a pig face show last year
and people bought tickets from me and uh,
they got a pair of tee shirts and it's
some coupons and some other stuff.
And so I'm sending her all these packages
to people have a list of all these
addresses of people who wanted to come
and see my band pig face. I'm like, well,
I've got to write a note
and I have to put their name on it.
I have to sign it, which makes perfect
sense. If you're talking to your grandma,
right,
there's 450 packages going out.
That's not nothing that
we put in a science CD,
which is not nothing to unwrap a bunch of
cds to sign and then let them dry them,
put them in. Then I put handfuls
of and assembles cause we're,
we're building or cementing or
reinvigorating these relationships.
So the efficiencies just not end it.
There needs to be a column
on the spreadsheet for Vibe
grooviness and something
else I can't think of. Right. That
shouldn't be on the spreadsheet.
Okay.
We'll talk about longevity in a bit,
but yeah.
No reason, no reason.
This slide, that slide,
sometimes it feels like he's pointing.
Get the fuck over.
Whatever it is. It's
something, just get over it.
Technical ability.
This is worth mentioning.
I think many of us want to
be really good at one thing.
Doesn't matter. I was hanging out
with John Langford from the metcons,
uh, Tuesday night and he said
he started the [inaudible].
He played Johnson and me comes
not because he was a good drummer,
he had a drum kit.
I was there and one of the guys,
the other guys in the past, if you want
to start with, none of us can play.
Should we start a band and they think
they're celebrating their 40th anniversary
this year.
He's a nine year old prodigy guitarists
on the Ellen degeneres show about to
meet Ozzie. He's a seven year
old drama with 13 million hits.
Whatever it is,
you're good at typing to youtube,
whatever your good at child prodigy.
Within three minutes you'll be
down at u break. I fix cars.
You cried into your laptop
and the salty tears,
what sparked me off keyboard.
There might be one or two people sit and
he goes, yeah, this doesn't apply to me.
I'm a pilot.
Yeah.
So is this five year old kid from China
always say yes to everything.
Difficult for me.
I'm kind of shy and uh,
if there's like,
okay,
so I'm bummed revealing this part of me.
You want to laugh?
Okay,
go ahead and left.
Ah,
this like a three year lag between
one of my slides in me actually doing
something about it, I've
just realized. Right. Um,
but I would say south by
southwest Edu and, uh, uh,
I met the mayor of Austin who's doing
some amazing shit right now for sure. And,
um, it was this long day and, uh,
just about to get in the elevator
and he's Canadian educators say, Hey,
let's go for Sushi. I'm like,
ah. I felt myself going, Eh, ah,
and I'm like, I'd like to, well, it's been
a long day, blah, blah, blah. Do you know,
uh,
and I'm like,
do you remember your slides from the
last four years? Mine? And I'm like, yes.
Had the most amazing time talking
about education in Canada.
It's very different than Canada,
obviously. Uh, so I use this,
the guy who kind of taught me that was
either beyond some from enslaved long
story, but, uh, it was kind of amazing.
Let's try,
can we,
let's have a pact between ourselves here
today to be more awesome than a pastor
restaurant.
Can we do that?
Does everybody agreed to be more
awesome than a pastor restaurant?
Because, uh, yeah, I feel you
thinking of what I thought,
he said, pastor, I should've
said pastor restaurant.
It shouldn't pastor restaurant.
But uh, they had this thing,
I think a year ago was, hey,
you want to come in and need some of
our pastor will watch your kids for two
hours? I'm like, wow.
So originally I put this slide in
my talk because it was like, wow.
And then I started to get upset,
like I'm pointing at a pastor
restaurant for us to like aspire to,
you know, and now I start to
see bands on Facebook. Well,
where Ohio, where were you
Friday? Where was everybody wears?
I seen what's going on.
Just having to go up.
People who didn't come to their show.
Nobody cares.
Nobody cares about anything
that's important to you for
a moment. I'm in a band.
Yeah, I'm a DJ or I'm a terrible
Dj. He didn't mention that. Josh,
I'm really bad. I will could destroy
your wedding. Not In a good way.
I could just completely
destroy your winning. But
I thought how many artists
would watch their fans kids,
right?
So let's aspire to do that.
Let's stop being shit start being awesome.
Your brand is a band and you want
to have your customers be fans.
So do your fines. Laundry. This
is where I lose everybody, right?
If I'm doing a music that
people just like, oh yeah.
Normally I'll say drugs will do
something to try and get people. But,
but you think about it, I don't know if
you've got, Google is here who are like,
hey, how's it going? I don't
know how you guys get along,
but there's gotta be some,
Hey, record release pie. Ah,
I'm busy. I haven't told you what it
is yet. Now, but I'm going to be busy.
Nobody cares.
So why not have your music release party?
You'll launch whatever is a longterm
mountain. Now the conversation different.
Hey, we're having a release party. Ooh.
And everybody gets two loads of
laundry to old. When is that?
Let me put, let me dial it.
Ain't no my phone. Boom,
because nobody cares.
I'm sure some people will show up,
but just get the long term,
screw them.
But you can manipulate the situation.
You can slide the owner of the laundromat
$50 would probably do it to like dial
back the temperature on the dryers.
So how far in you can be like,
hey, whoa, whoa, hey, sorry. Terribly
sorry. No disrespect to you Mike.
This is a fantastic laundromat.
There is a problem with the dryers
were putting in more dryer sheets.
We're going to keep the party going.
Somebody brought a case of beer.
Let's listen to the album more. More
time. People are like, fuck, you know,
what are people going to do?
You've got,
and they're held captive now
by their own wet laundry,
right?
Unsure five listens to you.
But yeah, two albums to listen.
So you could get away with,
it's a red bull and monster, but there
will be people who are called screw house,
screw the hat,
but at least I got clean underwear.
I'm thinking nine days later when
they still got clean underwear,
they're like, screw the
house guys. Ha ha ha, I win.
But you know what,
the songs are pretty good.
I kinda like him. Let me dial her up
again. I wonder if that playing close by,
right?
That's that trusting again.
Nobody cares about what's important to
you. Everyone's got doing underwear.
You win
as well.
We lose everybody else.
Get the fuck out of bed.
I'm lucky my kids have kind of grown now.
Coal is eight I was going to be nine soon,
but when he was three or four
most mornings, ah Eh. Ah,
before four 35 I'm getting
kicked in the back.
I've got congeal puke
across the back of my neck.
Similar to some of the situations.
I think you guys wake up in most mornings,
but here's the deal. I'm up at five.
I'm five hours ahead of my arch rival.
Ironically, the lead singer
in a band called arch rivals
five hours. Big Deal, but at the
end of the week, I'm 35 hours ahead.
That's 1000 I know you've
done the math in your head.
It's 1000 hundred and 20 hours a year.
76 days ahead.
That's the difference.
Just in case you're wondering,
they get the fuck out of bed.
A theme is also available as fantastic
performance hall pillowcase set
and uh,
I'm not just a crazy punk rocker.
You can't just have these slides up
at Google. You have to have cats.
The cats are swung it. No, this,
this get the fuck out of all of this cats.
I think those are no blacks cuts.
Dynasty podcast cats, the
dynasty podcasts. That's,
that has
a couple of quotes before I get to the,
the big huge stuff.
This is Dale Carnegie. My Dad
sent me this quote. Thanks Dad.
You can make more friends in two months
by being interested in other people.
Then you can make in two years trying to
get other people interested in you that
she's, I've like asterisk unless
you do the laundry, you know,
love that quote.
It's another good one about community
and neighbor is defined as one of the
resides 40 houses to one's right,
40 houses to one's left,
40 houses in front,
40 houses behind.
I think that's the correct.
Always be nice to everyone.
Be Nice to the people with the least
reason for you to be nice to them.
You can't be strategic about being nice,
just be nice.
The good thing is there were
some people being nice to them.
You'd have to buy them a
car and if someone's at that
point where you've got to
buy a car for them to go,
thanks for the car,
the car isn't going to
make a difference anyway.
The time to make a difference
is when it's a smile,
a sandwich not being an asshole.
Right.
That's a huge thing to do to be nice
to someone you don't know the context.
Maybe their partner just left them.
Maybe they just got this ridiculous
electric bill or a speeding fine or
something.
Just be nice.
See what I did here with the here,
it's so big.
It's like a typographic thing.
We don't have to get into it now.
I'll be sticking around afterwards.
How do we put 20,000 fans in the stadium?
I'm going to answer that question,
uh, more on my subscription site.
That's like a question, right? How do
we do that? How do we get to there?
On the billboard chart. Yeah.
Don't know. I don't fucking know,
but I know something.
I know every single person in this room
could make friends with two people today
of all days. You want to and we're
not going to do somewhat. Oh,
turn to the person. [inaudible] punch him
in the face it, I'm not going to do it,
but that's all this stuff is.
If you make two France today or six,
we're not going to do the math.
We'll keep it at twos. Right?
Every day you make two friends.
Now it gets a little bit played.
Spinny you've got to stay in touch with
the friends you made eight weeks ago.
Right? You've got to keep that plate
spinning, but that's all it is.
When you approach it as, how do we
put 20,000 people in, you're screwed.
If you're approaching it as,
I could make two friends today
and you get better at it,
you'll have days where you make 20 friends
or 20 potential longer term friends.
Right,
and you'll have days where you do do
some terrible stuff that doesn't make any
difference.
That's it.
There isn't any huge stuff.
There is a huge stuff.
There's just small stuff plus time.
That's all there is. And so we've
all been like, uh, what does that,
uh,
we're like a Stockholm syndrome,
prisoners of music business and the key
holders who want us to believe like,
oh one day we'll,
we'll it's behind this
curtain and actually there's
a door behind the curtain.
We could go through there. There's another
room with more curtains were pulled,
the curtains,
you get the key that gets the key to
the digital combination of the one day.
We'll take you there.
I said,
I want you to know this is
no fucking secret 20 event.
Just one day making to France
one day making two more friends.
You know, when I came up, uh,
a lot of really good things
happen to me very quickly.
I was on the front cover of melody maker.
That was just weird as hell.
He used to walk past the news agents on
my way to my government job when I was
18 in London, and that's the
melody maker, NME sounds,
all those magazines smash hits probably
and fantasize like one day that could be
me at the age of 18 I'm on the front
cover. We didn't live television.
We came over here,
we did American bandstand,
went to Japan and did all this stuff.
But I had this smash and grab
mentality of like, um, the,
I would have less time than a
superstar soccer player. Right.
What we got two years
grabbed a case of beer.
We're at not realizing I, you know, I
met Joe Shanahan from the Metro in 1991.
I still see him with his
kids, Dave and busters. Right?
He's just don't think like that.
You just like get the [inaudible] wish
[inaudible] Wa this just relationships,
people trust and community.
I want you to start looking at things
like that. The efficiency thing,
it's just a no brainer.
It doesn't matter if I'm creating a
relationship that could go on for touch
wood, there's no course,
there's no word in his
relationships that could
go on for 30 40 50 years.
It's the front end
takes whatever it takes.
It's not one thing.
It's hundred
or four 20
got the students back. Lost some
students with the laundry. Oh yeah.
This genius.
It's genius.
What he's saying now and big letters
for 24 20 big oh now losing it.
What's going on?
420,000
is the number.
Anybody know what that number is now?
Okay.
It's how many cats you get.
If you don't spay one cap,
Google it.
[inaudible]
well, if you don't Spec, of
course he's not from that one cap,
which I think you were thinking from
all the cats that come because of low
Spain. That cat, there's probably
eight the first time it has a litter,
but butt balm,
so what we need to be is,
well, we can't, we got to speak. I
don't want to say we shouldn't, right,
but one of my kids said to me,
this marketing thing,
dad,
it's like zombies.
It's like a Zombie thing.
Where are you going with this son?
Who you Harrison and,
and well,
it's like a Zombie by some person and
there's two and then those two zombies by
Tim benders for, it's like grains
of wheat on the chessboard, right?
Eight 1632.
So my last piece of advice to you is
to be a not splayed Zombie kitten.
This title of my next book.
That's rare,
but that's when we got to be not spayed.
Zombie kittens buying people having,
yeah.
And of course we always
need to throw muffins.
That's my shit.
[inaudible]
I don't have any control
over these bags of muffins.
Does anybody desperate for a muffin?
It's not code.
It's just once again,
please.
I ice forward icefall would
say
dining in the air.
Uh,
one of my favorite moments
that south by southwest,
I picked up, I picked up a box, right?
And I thought I couldn't get the little
bags all the way to the back. I thought,
well, I'll just, I'll kick this right.
There was somebody sitting there,
it hit,
I bet you've never heard such a bang
and just hit this guy in the face,
and we're still friends to this day,
which I'll just,
I don't know why I was saying anybody
want to go for the whole, well,
it's easy sitting down with
you. Find some muffins. Yeah.
I thought overall to talk was pretty good.
He made some good points and blah,
blah,
blah.
People don't realize the preparation
that goes into something like this.
Why I'm sitting up all night
opening these bags, masturbate in.
He his back, he Pete ceiling. It's just,
it's like six or seven hours right there.
That's my, that's my,
that's me. Thank you.